MATTHEW SPALDING: Welcome.
Welcome to Hillside College's
Washington, DC, campus.
I'm Matthew Spalding, the
vice president for the college
back here in
Washington, DC, and also
the dean of our new Van Andel
Graduate School of Government.
And I'm here this evening,
we are here this evening,
with a great friend of mine
and a wonderful scholar,
Amity Shlaes.
Amity was previously at the
Wall Street Journal's editorial
board and published
a weekly column
and wrote a great book in 1999
called The Greedy Hand, where
I first met her.
We had her do something
for that book.
She's written a
very important book
on the New Deal, The Forgotten
Man, A New History of the Great
Depression, of which there's
a graphic version, which
I have not seen, I have to say.
And then a book which
is a personal favorite,
although those are
great works, which
came to my attention,
wonderfully titled
just Coolidge,
she wrote in 2013.
And she's on the Calvin
Coolidge Presidential Foundation
Board, which I'm a big fan of.
So we have a number
of things in common.
But tonight, we're going to
talk about her new book, which
is The Great Society, A New
History, which is just out,
and we have copies of here
for all of you to buy.
And I have been reading it
and enjoying it immensely,
especially given the
connection between that book
and your previous
book on the New Deal.
And I'm struck, as I've
always been struck,
about how so many the questions
that we deal with today--
health care, education,
poverty, standards of living--
these are issues that came
out of the Great Society.
But you seem to be saying
it's not that great.
[LAUGHTER]
And indeed, it might
have had some problems.
AMITY SHLAES: Might have.
MATTHEW SPALDING: And
so I want to start
with some general
questions about the book,
but also about that period.
Because it turns out
there's a lot of things
we can learn from studying
that period that might
be extremely applicable today.
So start us off by, if we're
looking back in history,
how should we look at
what is the Great Society
and how should we
perceive that as a thing?
What do we make of that?
AMITY SHLAES: How should
we-- a great society--
I think you might
have seen this morning
that one of the presidential
candidates, Mike Bloomberg,
said it was time for
a war on poverty.
So that's a phrase
from the Great Society.
I think you always
start with what--
I would just stop and say
I'm very glad to be here,
and I'm very impressed with
Hillsdale, and a new graduate
school, and Dr. Spalding,
and the Van Andel Lecture
Hall and School.
What an achievement this is.
A presence that
was not here before
is here, and very central
and very admirable.
So what do we learn in school--
though maybe not at Hillsdale.
But what do we generally
learn in school
about the Great
Society in the '60s?
Well, the '60s are
taught non-logically.
That's the first thing to say.
So when you hear about
the '60s, it usually
tries to replicate the
kaleidoscope, maybe
the drug-related experience.
So there'll be loud music,
Woodstock, napalm, tragedy,
hippies, Nixon looking
bereaved and resentful.
And so it's almost hard
to get a logical picture.
Certainly, it's hard to get
a chronology of the period
from the way it's
taught, and that's
a separate problem to
the problems of earlier
periods where, for whatever
sins are contained in earlier
tellings of earlier periods,
they are usually chronological.
And man is chronological.
We need that.
Thematic is very difficult
for us to retain or analyze.
It's sort of pre-analyzed.
So that's the problem with the
history of the Great Society.
The biggest problem
is not left/right--
[CLEARS THROAT] excuse me-- or
where you are in the Vietnam
War or when you switched.
It's that it's taught more
with emotion and kaleidoscope
than with logic, to me.
So I said, well,
what is this period?
In the 1930s, we
had the New Deal.
And what is Great Society?
It sounds as
ambitious as New Deal.
And it was, in fact, more
ambitious because the New
Deal took place in a time of
genuine economic emergency.
If one in four is unemployed,
that's a real problem,
and people have to
come up with an answer.
And Franklin Roosevelt-- before
him, Herbert Hoover-- did.
And we may not like
the answer and have
had another that we would have
liked to have applied in 1932
or '33, but there's
the unavoidable fact
of the national emergency.
This is a different story
because we were actually doing
pretty well in the early '60s.
Everything seemed to be
getting better in every way.
The '50s were a
pretty good decade.
Everything seemed to be
getting better in every way.
And we'll come back
to this, Matthew,
but you know that poverty
went down dramatically,
if you want to make war on
poverty, in the 1950s basically
because of economic growth.
So what's the thing you give a
poor person more than anything
else that he wants?
A job, right?
And so the '50s turned out to be
a great decade with jobs, even
sometimes with benefits.
And we thought, oh, well,
given how strong we are
and that we're a
superpower and all,
let's just clean up the rest
of our little problems-- cure
poverty, as Franklin
Roosevelt said.
And I remember the writer,
Norman Podhoretz, said,
we all thought poverty
could be cured.
This was, just
after World War II,
for those who had fought
in World War II, a kind
of mopping-up action, domestic.
Because if you can win Europe
or defeat Japan, of course
you can help poor people,
and all will be better.
That was the very ambitious
attitude in the early '60s.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Yeah,
there's a great chart
in the back of the book
showing the decline.
It's very small [INAUDIBLE],,
but showing the decline
of the rate of poverty.
But then it kind of
flattens out after that.
AMITY SHLAES:
That's right, yeah.
And I want to mention
here John Cogan of Hoover
who wrote a fantastic book
called The High Cost of--
MATTHEW SPALDING:
Good intentions.
AMITY SHLAES: --Good
Intentions, yeah.
Anyway, it's all data,
and it's all true.
So he also gets at this point.
We did not cure poverty even
though Franklin Roosevelt hoped
we might and Lyndon
Johnson swore we would.
We may have brought
it down a bit at first
when the Great Society started.
And you look at that chart, and
you see poverty going down sort
of as fast--
and you can look at the points
underlying the PowerPoint
and decide--
as it did in the 1950s.
And then poverty, by
the official definition
established by our government,
leveled off at 10%,
a little more.
And it's still there.
So curing poverty didn't happen.
That was the promise
of the Great Society,
and it didn't happen.
That's the main thing.
And I'm really happy to have
the Framers here instead
of a PowerPoint for you.
MATTHEW SPALDING:
[LAUGHS] So you've
already alluded to the
comparison between the Great
Society and the New Deal.
Let's broaden that
a bit and look
at the various, what
we want to call,
waves of liberalism
in the 20th century.
Because the other
one we have to add
to that is the early
Progressive movement.
And it strikes me that it might
be that the Great Society has
actually more similarities
to the early Progressives.
I mean, there was a
sense that somehow they
could fix things through
expertise and more government
than--
where do you put
the Great Society
in this larger motif of
what modern liberalism did
over the 20th century?
AMITY SHLAES: Well,
we used to think
that Progressive social
workers worked where?
In the states.
The lady from the state of
Missouri or from the county
came to your house and said
whatever she had to say.
They might be funded by the
federal government in part,
but it came from the states.
So early Progressivism,
the kind that
inspired Theodore Roosevelt, was
in the state of Massachusetts,
in the state of New York.
And that's where the
Progressives came from.
We never imagined we would
be running the social work
business from Washington
even in times of prosperity.
Most of us didn't, anyhow.
So what happened in the
early 1960s is we said,
forget the states.
The federal government
needs to do this.
Only the federal
government can do it.
And the book opens actually
with Michael Harrington,
who was a socialist.
He didn't work for Moscow.
What was wrong with
these socialists
was not that they were traitors.
It was that they were wrong
about their philosophy, right?
A nice man, kind of
an early JD Vance.
He focused on hillbillies.
They had a problem.
Some of that was social.
Let's figure that
out-- alcohol trouble,
you know-- and wrote a book
called The Other America.
And he said, the
problem of America,
these deep-seated problems of
families and no food sometimes,
or the wrong food,
or wrong attitudes,
only the federal government
is capable of solving this.
Only Washington.
And there was some consensus
for that even beginning
under Kennedy, although Kennedy
didn't get the legislation.
And it only strengthened.
Only Washington can do this.
And remember-- I'll
just say one last thing.
A lot of the men who were
leading our country-- and they
were mostly men-- were what?
Veterans.
So most of the time--
this is before Vietnam--
they had seen the federal
government do something good,
win a war.
And they might have had a
benefit or one or the other.
When they came home, they
might have had GI Bill.
They might have had
subsidy for housing
that made entry-- and
certainly education.
And there are people in
this room probably who--
it was the attitude of
Daniel Patrick Moynihan.
I never had to pay for school
because the government took
care of me.
I trust the government.
So they did trust
the government,
the federal government,
at a very high level.
MATTHEW SPALDING: So
does the Great Society
grow out of the New Deal?
Does it grow out of
this earlier root?
Is it something different?
Is there a shift in liberalism?
AMITY SHLAES: It's just more--
MATTHEW SPALDING:
What is your read?
AMITY SHLAES: It's
just more ambitious.
So it grows.
I mean, if you look
for logic in it,
you can find strands of logic
depending on the person, right?
But what it was was
a general consensus
that we had to do something.
And imagine we're
having a theater.
In the background, the bombs
are going off all the time.
Offstage-- that's
Vietnam, right?
Offstage, the battle
rumbles, and the tension
of sending 400,000, 500,000
people very suddenly over
to Asia is there.
So this idea,
Vietnam is a strand.
The Progressive
impulse is a strand.
And another strand is Lyndon
Johnson's personal ambition.
Lots of biographers--
[INAUDIBLE],, most recently--
have covered that.
But here's a person who's
the child of the New Deal.
He was a Roosevelt pleaser,
a very effective congressman.
And it was said--
there's a cartoon.
If you want something done
quick in the New Deal,
you get Lyndon
Johnson, the young man
who worked with youth
in the state of Texas,
and actually had to tell the
farmers they should plow over
their crops, and that
was economic logic.
You plow over your crop,
and then you get money
from the federal government.
And the farmers, he had
to convince the farmers.
And the farmers were kind
of dubious about that,
and their mules were
even more dubious
because the mules
in Texas are trained
not to step on the little
fledgling plants, right?
The whole experience of a
mule is not to step on plants.
And here, they were
destroying something.
So Lyndon Johnson did yeoman
service to Franklin Roosevelt
on executing a sometimes
nonsensical New Deal.
And he said, when I
grow up, I'm going
to finish Franklin
Roosevelt's agenda,
and I'm going to finish
Harry Truman's agenda.
Harry Truman wanted
something like Medicare.
He hadn't got it through.
Johnson was deeply
proud, a proud man,
that he could get that through.
But you want to
think he's ambitious,
so he plays to his strengths,
a master of the Senate.
And I don't even focus too
much on Johnson in the book,
so we'll stop there.
Because he's just
part of the story.
But that's him,
ambition and glory.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Right,
perhaps even being greater
than the New Deal.
AMITY SHLAES: Yeah.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Because
one of your charts
shows how the Great
Society programs actually
are larger than the New Deal
programs at a certain point.
AMITY SHLAES: Oh,
of course, yeah.
And if you have a chart
which we have in the back,
you will see that our
commitments to the Great
Society cost more
than our commitments
to New Deal programs today.
That is, the papers
our lawmakers
signed in the '60s committed
us to spending more
today than even the New Deal.
What's interesting is the Walter
Lippmann, the commentator,
wrote a critique
of the New Deal.
And it was called
a Good Society.
And one reason Walter
Lippmann called it good
was he was signaling we should
draw back from these Superman
ambition projects.
Great.
But great is wrong.
Good.
But Johnson liked "great."
He was very proud of the phrase.
He introduced it at the
University of Michigan in 1964.
And if not great, then not
at all, was his attitude.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Right.
I think the phrase "Great
Society" was actually
used by John Dewey at one.
It's actually an old
Progressive phrase--
AMITY SHLAES: Yes, it was even--
MATTHEW SPALDING: --in an essay.
AMITY SHLAES: --used by the
Fabian Socialists in England.
MATTHEW SPALDING:
Yeah, so it does
actually have a history to it.
AMITY SHLAES: And we will
have great-- in England,
it also means big, right?
It doesn't just mean high.
So by "great society,"
actually in England,
they meant a society that is
networked from town to town
across the country.
Because before the
railroad and the telegraph,
towns were pretty isolated.
And now we had a great
society, and the newspapers
began to come on the
train in the morning,
and we could hear what was going
on in London in practically
real time.
That was what the Fabian
Socialists imagined.
But they also
imagined, right away,
that if a society is
great, broad, high,
it must have great planners.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Right.
AMITY SHLAES: You can see
that in the language too.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Yes.
AMITY SHLAES: And planning is
a huge part of Great Society,
ours, in the '60s.
MATTHEW SPALDING:
Right, that's what
I mean, the sense of going
back to the early Progressives,
planning and expertise.
So the main elements
of the Great Society--
correct me if I'm wrong--
in LBJ, his famous speech,
health care, health, education,
the environment.
Are those really the main areas?
AMITY SHLAES: Yeah,
he had cities.
He classed them cities,
country, classroom.
And all those things are--
MATTHEW SPALDING:
Why those, and what
was their thinking on them?
AMITY SHLAES: Well, we did
need some environmental law
or environmental habit.
That was clear.
This was the era when you
couldn't drive through Gary
because it smelled too bad.
We did, but you had to
roll up the window, right?
LBJ was very
concerned about-- he
was very much of a car person.
You don't see him walking a lot.
And I think America would
be different if presidents
could walk down the street
because he was a vehicular
president.
He had an amphibious car.
So he liked to
beautify highways.
Lady Bird did along with
beginning in the environment.
Of course, Nixon did
more, and I include
Nixon in the Great Society.
One of the revisions
of this book
is that Nixon is really
just a follow-on to Johnson.
The classroom, Johnson
was a school teacher,
so that appealed to him.
And he believed, rightly, I
would say-- and you would too,
probably-- that
education is much
of the answer to the
ills of poor families.
If they know more, they
can earn more money.
And--
MATTHEW SPALDING:
OK, so one could
say that's a reasonable argument
for those three areas of--
AMITY SHLAES: Right.
MATTHEW SPALDING: --involvement.
How did it become
the Great Society?
Was this good
intentions gone bad?
Was this the fatal
conceit of planning?
Was this just great ambition
to get the federal government
involved?
Was it to build--
what's the--
AMITY SHLAES: Well,
it was a power drive.
We want to stay in
power, so we want
to do more and more
impressive things
so people will re-elect us.
That's the way-- the book ends
with Nixon seeking re-election.
But I'm not sure
what you're asking.
What I do say in the book,
what I show in the book,
is first they tried
the war on poverty,
and they had weird
results with that.
The Poverty Law, the
Economic Opportunity Act,
which created the Poverty
Office of Sargent Shriver,
seemed a fairly harmless
law, but actually did
quite a bit of harm.
What am I thinking of?
Many in this room are concerned
about federalism, right?
What is the state in
charge of, and what
is a town in charge of?
We had poverty in
American cities.
The mayors all had poverty.
People-- maybe they called
them assistance, not poverty,
but they had poverty people.
Many of the mayors
were Democrats.
They helped Lyndon Johnson
get elected in 1964.
I'm thinking here
of Richard J. Daly.
And so when Johnson
declared war on poverty,
Richard J. Daly put
all his poverty ideas
in a box, a big box,
mailed it to Washington.
Here's what I need money
for that you owe me
because of what I gave you.
And that is not what came out of
the poverty czar office because
of the infatuation with
reform and sometimes
Social Democratic,
or we would sometimes
call them socialist ideas.
What came out of that office
was Sargent Shriver, a nice man,
brother-in-law of the late
president, kind of noble,
hard to dislike, veteran,
created the Peace Corps,
running this, sent his own
poverty people to the towns.
And I'm thinking
some of the people
in the room may
have known of that
or been part-- his
own poverty people.
And those poverty people
believed in community activism,
by which they meant,
let's go to the town hall
and protest and try to
get whatever we need here.
We thought it would be
jobs, but it ended up
being housing,
landlords, and so on.
And the mayors could
not believe it.
They had elected Lyndon
Johnson, and now Johnson's very
own people were bothering
them in their mayor office,
disturbing their day,
and not helping them
with their problem of poverty.
And in the book,
I tell this story
of Sam Yorty, the mayor
of Los Angeles, who
said, there will be riots in
Los Angeles unless you help me,
President Johnson, basically,
with my poverty programs.
And he got into a
jurisdictional squabble
with the Poverty Office,
the mayor of Los Angeles
versus Sargent Shriver,
[INAUDIBLE] all spring.
And the money that was
promised didn't come.
What's worse than no money?
Money that was promised
and doesn't come.
What's worse than money
that's never promised?
Money that was promised.
And that failure of Yorty--
and it was his
failure too-- to bring
the money he said would be
there to create hundreds
and hundreds of jobs
for the youth of Watts
contributed to the
rage in Watts, along
with all the other
factors that are
more famous, such as the rough
police department and so on.
So sometimes when you have
multiple jurisdiction,
all you have is jurisdictional
lacunae and chaos, right?
And that often happened.
The other mayors
also complained.
Daly said, does the president
know he's sending M-O-N-E-Y
to--
I can't remember what
he put, but subversive,
some word like subversives.
Does he know that?
Daly couldn't believe it, that
Johnson would be so naive.
And I think Johnson
himself was not
really aware of what
Shriver was doing.
And Shriver just wanted
to get things done fast,
and Johnson was pressuring him.
So this was a great--
Shriver is one of
the fools of my book
because he was a nice
man who did a naive thing
and paid for it terribly.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Right, right.
So let's try to draw out
some broader lessons here,
and then we'll open
it up for questions.
AMITY SHLAES: Oh, sure.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Because
there's a lot in your book
which I found
fascinating about how
there was a push for an idea,
perhaps because of idealism,
perhaps because of politics--
but then there's often
a compromise or a push
back by people like Wilbur Mills
or Daniel Patrick Moynihan.
But they got taken
on that because it
took on a life of its own.
Is the lesson here, beware
of idealism and government
coming together?
Is it unintended consequences?
Is it, don't compromise
with idealists and zealots?
I mean, what's the larger--
AMITY SHLAES: Beware
of marginal increases,
and we know that
from government.
Wilbur Mills--
MATTHEW SPALDING:
Some of these were--
because you were pointing
out that-- so Medicare
was an add-on.
It was going to be a small
add-on program that was agreed
to, but then it became--
AMITY SHLAES: Yeah,
and Wilbur Mills--
MATTHEW SPALDING: What do we
learn from this for today?
Because this is
what we're debating.
AMITY SHLAES: Wilbur Mills was--
MATTHEW SPALDING: It's
the kind of debates
we're having today
about what we should do.
AMITY SHLAES: He
was a chairman--
he was known as the
Powerful Wilbur Mills--
I think, until I was 10, I
thought his name was Powerful--
because the influence of the
Ways and Means Committee.
And Wilbur Mills was a
government expander, but also
a pragmatist.
And he went along with
Medicare and kind of liked it
because of a lot of
other trades he had
going in his complex business.
And then Medicare cost a lot
more than he thought it would,
and he was embarrassed.
He had told his
constituents at home
it wouldn't cost this much.
And he became wise.
Everett Dirksen is the same way.
Everett Dirksen
supported Johnson
on civil rights, which was
very important to the end
of the filibuster of laws
that are very important that
are also in this period.
But when he came
to some labor laws,
Everett Dirksen said,
uh-uh, count me out.
This is too much support
of organized labor.
So I think if you would pick a
philosopher, it would be Hayek.
And why Hayek?
If you haven't heard of him
or don't know about him,
Hayek spoke of a thing
called the knowledge problem.
And basically what
it says is government
is insulated from knowledge
by the political process.
You only get feedback in an
election every four years,
maybe every two years,
every six years, right?
And you only talk to your
friends in government.
Whereas the small business
is in the market every day.
And by night, it knows
whether it did well
with its product that day and
perhaps even how to adjust it.
So the government
was so insulated
from reality, most of the
time, it couldn't really
figure out what it was doing
or what was wrong about that.
And Hayek, of course,
also has Road to Serfdom.
And what Road to Serfdom
says is we're not
living in Zeno's paradox.
You actually do get
to serfdom even if you
take little steps, right?
It's not like, oh,
we'll never get there.
You actually get to serfdom
because entrenched interest
groups-- in this case,
the silent majority,
the forgotten men-- once
they have a benefit,
as [INAUDIBLE] said, they
don't want to let it go.
And when there are
enough entrenched groups,
it's very hard to reform.
And I feel even silly
saying this in Washington,
where you know
this better than I.
MATTHEW SPALDING: [LAUGHS] Let's
open up for some questions.
I know that there's some
microphones, I believe.
Fellow right there in the back.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very
much for coming to speak.
One of the things--
maybe a little less now, but
certainly 10 or more years ago,
folks who were alive
either who were
of the so-called
silent generation
or of the very older so-called
baby boomer generation,
will often say, if
Vietnam hadn't happened,
the Great Society
would have worked.
It would have been tremendous.
I have known myself people
alive from that time period
or activists or professors
who've told me that and said,
if it had just been fully funded
and Vietnam hadn't happened,
everything would
have been great.
I am skeptical of that, but I'm
wondering how you particularly
answer that question.
AMITY SHLAES: Well,
I would refer to you
the chart on page 440--
or sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
Or maybe 439.
That's the answer.
What people began to
realize, that Vietnam
is the great excuse story.
And Vietnam did help
to bring about some
of the more expansive
bits of legislation.
You could say the Great
Society wouldn't--
MATTHEW SPALDING: Are you
talking about the butter price
here, the guns chart?
AMITY SHLAES: Yeah.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Page 435.
AMITY SHLAES: Page 435.
But what I'm saying is
maybe the Great Society
would have been just the
Good Society without Vietnam
because you have to have
something really good at home.
That's the opposite to what
people are arguing with you.
And second, even in the
'60s, by the late '60s,
people saw that the butter at
home, the domestic programs,
were going to cost
more than the guns.
That line was crossed.
I believe it's in
early '70s, '71.
And even today, we
have this fallacy
that defense costs so much.
When you look at the
whole budget, which
includes mandatory spending,
defense does not cost so much.
It costs a relatively
small share of our economy
compared to history,
period of the Korean War.
So this argument isn't reality.
And the reason, for
example, that we
had the fiscal crisis of
1971 and the stagflation
and high interest rates of the
'70s is not mostly Vietnam.
It's the Great Society.
And that's very-- foreigners
looked at the US and said,
it's going kind of
Social Democratic.
That's like us, which means its
growth advantage may be eroded.
Its growth advantage-- the
US had a growth advantage.
It was a freer
market than Europe.
That growth advantage, that
gap between Scandinavia
and Michigan, is narrowing
in terms of social cost.
And therefore, the US
might not be so strong.
So there are plenty
of pieces of data that
refute your friend's argument.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yes, Ms.
Shlaes, isn't it the case
the reason the Utopianism
of the Great Society
was almost unchallenged
was because there
was a lack of faith
in civil society
and especially even in
the Republican Party
after Dwight Eisenhower
took the party over
and Robert Taft died
of cancer in 1953?
And in academe too.
I mean, there were just
a few marginal people.
In 1953, Robert Nesbitt
and Russell Kirk each
published classics The
Quest for Community
and the Conservative Tradition,
but they were considered
wackos in outside society.
AMITY SHLAES: They
were considered wackos.
AUDIENCE: The Austrian
economist too.
And the voter registration
was 2 and 1/2 Democratic
to Republicans.
Isn't this the
reason why Johnson--
and Johnson was a master of
the legislative process--
that the chance to commit the
Great Society even occurred?
AMITY SHLAES: That's a
very important question.
I used to have a debate with
Jonathan Alter of Newsweek.
And he would say, before the New
Deal, Amity, there was nothing.
And before the New Deal,
there was something.
It was just local.
It was the Italian
American Burial Society,
or it was the county of x,
y, z and its little hospital
led by--
there was a--
David [INAUDIBLE]
has a beautiful book
about Tocqueville in America
which I always give to kids.
And all the little weird
institutions, Mooseheart,
the orphanage, very--
AUDIENCE: Still there.
Still there.
AMITY SHLAES: Right?
Yeah, still there.
So Yeah, there was a contempt
for Tocqueville America.
It seemed quaint and old.
And it was a terrible contempt
because Tocqueville still
makes America the little town.
I have a chapter on the
fragility of the municipality
where Tocqueville writes
about the fragility
of the municipality can be--
it's like a consumptive patient.
It could die any time,
that municipality,
because the big state, by
which Tocqueville probably
meant the county or the state--
that is, state of Illinois,
Springfield, Albany--
might step on it
or pull the cord.
So when you want to think about
Tocqueville's America in this
period, I have a long
description of the housing
program at Pruitt-Igoe in
St. Louis and what they did
to the Tocqueville of
downtown St. Louis,
which very proud town-- maybe
some of you are from there--
with very local, strong, "let's
support each other" tradition
just wrecked by urban
renewal and bulldozers.
And I will just
say one last thing.
For the middle class, we
had something of Tocqueville
in our housing funding
because we said,
we'll give middle-class
people subsidized mortgages
so they can settle in little
communities, the new suburbs,
right?
And then they can have
a cul-de-sac and a car,
and their children
can play there.
And they'll build
a new community,
and we'll fund that,
the federal government.
That's also Levittown.
That's for middle-class people.
For poor people, they
can have Karl Marx,
and we'll build big, tall,
really ugly buildings
in the international
style, which
we kind of admire
but tends to make
people feel sad and lonely.
And we'll send them
up in elevators.
And in the halls, they'll be
beat up by wayward children,
and there'll be no commerce
at all around them.
And certainly, then let's
bulldoze the churches
around the edge.
Because we're bulldozing
whole communities,
so most of the churches go too.
And all the other
Tocqueville institutions
that happen to have
been there around where
the new tall buildings go.
And at the end of
the book, I describe
how, after all the successive
waves of Progressivism
and non-Tocquevillism at
St. Louis' Pruitt-Igoe,
they had to, as in
Chicago, blow it up.
MATTHEW SPALDING: But
wasn't one of the--
to go back to an earlier point
you made, there's a certain--
politics is never
about one or the other
in those absolute ways.
It's very rarely that
kind of question.
One of the things the Great
Society took advantage of
was a natural
American desire to try
to solve some of these
problems, poverty,
to allow for growth
and expansion
and a national economy, right?
So they drove right
through that because there
was a-- as the nation grew
and the economy grew and it
became larger, there
was a need to solve
some of these problems.
They just thought
they could perfect it
by using Washington
programs to do so.
AMITY SHLAES: When
I was writing--
yeah.
So we want a great society.
We're ambitious.
It's 1960.
We're teenagers, and we don't
remember World War II, right?
The boomers were like
the woke students
now who say, hey, boomer, right?
Boomers were the generational
divide, the rebellion.
And they said, we want
to do something great.
The only question
is, by what means?
Through the public sector,
or the private sector?
Well, we opted for
the public sector.
And what is the private sector?
It's the milk cow that funds it.
And you know what?
If you leave the private
sector alone enough,
it usually can fund
a lot of whatever
you want to do with your
Great Society vision.
So in the book when
I was writing it,
I decided to tell the
story of three companies--
General Electric; Toyota, which
intervenes suddenly in Detroit;
and the company
that became Intel.
And these companies
did social things.
Number one, they created jobs.
Number two, in Fairchild, which
is the predecessor to Intel,
for example, at a factory on
a Native American reservation,
it became the greatest
private sector
employer of Native Americans.
Because this particular
Native American group
worked with their hands,
did a lot of handiwork,
like weaving, basically, or
what we would call needlepoint,
and making chips involves the
same skills plus a magnifying
glass, right?
So the private sector
can do more than we
think to solve social problems.
And that was it.
But we opted for
the public sector.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Of
course, one of the greatest
spokesmen for GE was--
AMITY SHLAES: Well, I tell
this story at the beginning.
They had an actor
who worked for GE
who was kind of old and not even
that good, a little bit corny.
And he was hired to propagandize
for the free market,
and that was Reagan.
So Reagan, there he was.
He was a middle-aged man now.
And he gave not just 50 or
100, but maybe 1,000 speeches
about markets to the rubber
chicken circuit of the hundred
plants of General Electric
because General Electric
was concerned that its
workers didn't understand
that capitalism was fragile.
And it all was for naught--
I mean in chapter 1--
because GE suffered
a terrible embarrassment in
its employees, fixed prices,
and deals with Westinghouse.
It was described as a
sports scandal for America
because people respected GE
as they respect baseball.
And it went down in the world,
and they fired the actor,
and they fired his
boss, Lem Boulware.
And they got rid of all
the little propaganda
mill programs.
And they thought, what a waste.
We screwed up.
But Reagan remembered and
eventually became a convert
to these ideas.
He came to believe in markets
by background, a New Dealer.
So that story is told.
MATTHEW SPALDING: So
since you brought that up,
Reagan, in his 1982
diary, famously
writes, "The press
is trying to paint me
as trying to undo the New Deal.
I remind them I voted
for FDR four times.
I'm trying to undo
the Great Society.
It was LBJ's war on poverty
that led to our present mess."
AMITY SHLAES: Very interesting.
I don't have that in
the book, I don't think.
Is that-- yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
In the next book.
So I mean, the history is--
MATTHEW SPALDING: He saw the
Great Society as the enemy
to be defeated.
AMITY SHLAES: Absolutely.
History is history, but
it's also characters.
They don't have
to be presidents.
They can be just the next line.
So there was a book called
Best and the Brightest
about the foolish errors of
arrogant men in the Vietnam
War, planning the Vietnam
War and the execution,
the negotiation,
the prosecution.
There's a domestic Best
and the Brightest that
is a bunch of guys who
were so smart they thought
they could do this,
not just Sarge Shriver,
but also Walter Reuther.
And where is Reagan?
He's like the mayors because he
became governor of California.
And he had lots of things to
do, and the federal government
kept getting in the way.
And there's a hilarious
scene where the governors had
a kind of way of vetoing a
federal project, a poverty
project, but it wasn't
a really good veto.
They could be
overruled, basically.
So he was going to
overrule something
the Nixon administration
was doing,
which was funding
public interest lawyers.
And Nixon didn't want
that because Nixon
knew, in his heart, that Reagan
was just as popular as he was--
Nixon, right?
This is a very awkward
moment, and you
have the lawyers for
Nixon, the president,
and the lawyers for Reagan--
one of them was Ed Meese--
in a room.
And the scary administration,
led by Frank Carlucci,
said, kind of very
condescendingly to the Reagan
crowd using a film
metaphor because Reagan
would understand that, right?
There's an A movie where
you blow this all up
and we blow you up.
And forgive me.
I don't have the text here,
but something like that.
And there's a B
movie where we make
a compromise and neither of
us loses face on this "lawyers
funded by Washington" thing.
And maybe we'll help you with
your welfare cutbacks, which
is your big pride,
Governor Reagan.
And Meese goes into another room
and presumably phones Reagan,
and comes back and says,
we take the B movie.
[LAUGHTER]
And then Reagan, I
think he sent Carlucci
a bottle of an
alcoholic substance.
I believe it might
have been scotch.
So that was Reagan,
the governor.
He decided this
had all worked out.
It wasn't just scorch
and burn, right?
MATTHEW SPALDING: Right, right.
AMITY SHLAES: But
the welfare program
became a model for welfare
reform later, Reagan's own
and then also Clinton's, right?
MATTHEW SPALDING:
[INAUDIBLE] yeah.
AMITY SHLAES: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Ms. Shlaes,
thank you for coming.
Christopher Harris with
Unhyphenated America, and I
just have a quick question.
My family's originally
from Detroit.
And Walter Williams has talked
about the effect of the Great
Society on the black
family in particular.
And you talk about how the
poverty was decreasing,
had decreased
dramatically part of that.
And I've talked to many
of my family members
and they say, look,
everybody that they grew up
with-- my father's 69 years old.
And basically, everybody
they grew up with
had a mother and a
father and a home.
I mean, there was
a handful of people
who did not have a mother
and a father and a home.
And afterwards-- like, I'm 46--
you'll see the large percentage
of people in my generation
did not grow up with a
mother and father at home.
Why do you think that
the New Deal didn't
have such a destructive effect
on the black family or families
in general as such as
the Great Society has
had on families in general?
MATTHEW SPALDING:
That's a great question.
AMITY SHLAES: Thank you.
Great question.
Actually, the family
separation issue--
the most proximate
thing to which you refer
is to get welfare money, you
had to be a single parent.
And the welfare money--
and then, on top of that,
to get subsidized housing.
So some of that was
pre-Great Society.
It was state welfare
law, for example,
which said we won't
support men who earn,
but we'll support families
with dependent children
and no worker mom.
So it was a perverse outcome
from a well-meaning plan.
And in my description of
Pruitt-Igoe, this housing
project, which was
rather like the housing
projects in Detroit, the dads
had to hide in the closet
when the social worker came
because they would lose
not only the money, but also
the family would the apartment
if the dad were discovered.
And where is the
dad supposed to go?
Far away and get a job?
That was a huge factor
which the Great Society,
through the format
of its funding,
perpetuated and strengthened.
And it wasn't just
black families.
It was white families as well.
I would add another
factor, though.
I really don't
like urban renewal.
That was my note.
I'm paraphrasing, but
it says, urban renewal
is minority removal.
And when the riots
happened in Detroit,
it was said it was the people
who had been bulldozed out
of old neighborhoods
which were not only poor,
not only occasionally slums,
but also lively and much loved,
bulldozed out of
their homes to be put
in sterile vertical projects.
And they were angry and sad.
They were displaced
and displaced.
They were displaced by slavery.
Then they were displaced
when they moved north.
And then they were displaced
again from that place
where they originally lived
when they moved to Detroit.
That's a lot of
displacement for a family.
So I try to describe
that in the book,
and I very much appreciate
your raising that issue.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Another
character in your book
is Daniel Patrick Moynihan
who, of course, wrote
a report on the black family
and then was later vilified.
Tell us about him.
AMITY SHLAES: The first
person in my lifetime
I know about who was ever
canceled, Daniel Patrick
Moynihan because he wrote a
book trying to describe trouble
in a single-parent family,
particularly maybe when
the father, who departed
or is infrequently present,
is alcoholic.
And by the way, that's Daniel
Patrick Moynihan's life.
He just happens to be white.
So his father was not there,
and there were other fathers
occasionally.
And this was problematic
for the Moynihans.
So he tried to describe
that question which you just
put your finger on.
And pretty soon, it became to
seem condescending for a white
person to describe
something that, what,
is supposed to be uniquely
black, which it isn't.
And he was shut out
by the Democrats.
And so I spend a lot
of time on Moynihan
and his humiliation
and loneliness
because he was actually a
very insightful guy with a lot
to contribute to government.
And his revenge was to come
back working for Richard Nixon
and offer a program that sounds
very familiar today, which
is guaranteed income
for whites and blacks
below a certain income level.
But the canceling of Moynihan
by the world and Cambridge,
Massachusetts, is a bitter
and fiery thing to behold.
MATTHEW SPALDING: This
gentleman over here.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very
much for your talk tonight.
One question.
So at the very
beginning, you talked
about how the early
Progressives were very much more
focused on the states.
It was very much more of a
smaller level than federal.
And it sounds to me
like later on, it's
really with the Great
Society that you
see the progressive thought take
root in that federal portion.
Woodrow Wilson talks
very much in his writings
about the idea of a hive mind.
He talks about how there's
this general aggregate where
everything centralizes
in Washington.
And to provide an
analogy, a lot of people
provide how Lincoln almost
acts as a fulfillment
for the American founding.
So in a similar way,
if you want to think
of the progressive
thought with Wilson
as a re-founding or
revolution, could you
say almost that that
fulfillment comes about
in the Great Society?
AMITY SHLAES: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
Another question.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Would
you care to elaborate?
AMITY SHLAES:
[INAUDIBLE] remember--
did you ever read God and Man
at Yale by William F. Buckley?
I never read it because I
wasn't interested particularly
in the God part.
But what it's really--
the meat of it was they
changed the way they
teach economics in college.
Gee whiz.
We used to teach about
individuals and--
I don't know-- the
invisible hand and so on.
And now, all of a sudden,
it's all about planning.
So that commenced this big
sea change at universities
right after World
War II, which meant
15 years worth of
undergraduates had
been schooled in this
planning way of thinking.
So now the grownups didn't
know much about free markets
or care about them.
They knew about planning.
And so those people were
ready to takeover around 1960.
They had become the
grownups and the leaders.
MATTHEW SPALDING:
Yeah, and that planning
grows out of the philosophical
roots of the early progressives
who thought that
progressive experts could
solve all problems.
AMITY SHLAES: Right.
And also, there's a
cumulative effect.
Planning upon planning
yields perversity.
Oh, we had that
reform last year.
Oh, this is the 17th
definition of child
we've had in the tax code, and
each one contradicts the other,
and five are still [INAUDIBLE].
MATTHEW SPALDING: It also goes
back to the fellow's point
here, which is
they always, oh, it
didn't work because there was
some factor that was not right.
We'll try it again.
AMITY SHLAES: We'll try--
right.
This is like a book with a bunch
of progressive waves within it,
and they get bigger and bigger.
And the magnitudes of
dollars get bigger.
Because at the very
beginning, Michael Harrington
hears from Sargent Shriver.
They're going to get a
billion dollars for welfare.
And Michael Harrington says,
that's just nickel and dimed.
We need more than a billion.
And Sargent Shriver says,
I don't know about you,
young man, but I never had
a billion to spend before.
I think it feels pretty big.
But of course, the numbers
did go Harrington-wise
into the mag--
even add a few zeros.
MATTHEW SPALDING: So
that conversation,
just not to be a
spoiler, but it's
the very beginning
of the book, and she
doesn't identify who
the two people are
until you get several pages
into the conversation.
And it sounds eerily
like a conversation
you might hear today in
the halls of Congress
about very large programs,
very large idealistic ideas
about what government
ought to be doing.
Why didn't we learn
any of these lessons?
Why are we doing this again?
AMITY SHLAES: Oh.
MATTHEW SPALDING: [INAUDIBLE]
AMITY SHLAES: Well,
the motto of the book,
which I will say I have
heard Chanel, Coco Chanel,
say, but also other important
people, nothing is new.
It is just forgotten.
Nothing is new.
The grammar's a little
awkward, but I still like it.
Nothing is new, but
it is just forgotten.
We forgot the '70s, which
were the consequence.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Well, they
were a forgettable decade.
AMITY SHLAES: They were
definitely forgettable.
[LAUGHTER]
So I try to explain the '70s
to myself and other people.
The '70s was a period when we
thought our houses would be
smaller than our parents--
and they technically
were at certain points.
And we had two fewer
bedrooms than we actually
needed because the
interest rate was 18%.
That it was a period
where we didn't think
we would ever have enough
energy to heat our homes.
And I don't even want
to write the '70s
because it's a little dark.
I have to figure
out a happy '70s.
MATTHEW SPALDING: [LAUGHS]
AMITY SHLAES: But you think
of, those of you will remember,
the ratcheting down
of expectation,
the emphasis on
scarcity, is reminiscent
of the current
environmental movement.
I mean, there was a philosopher
named Paul Ehrlich who actually
believed there should be a
very heavy tax on diapers
so that people would
have fewer babies.
And also, we should change the
tax code-- no child credit,
none of that--
and to discourage reproduction
because we wouldn't
be able to feed ourselves.
And more importantly, we
were the world's model.
And how about introducing
the vasectomy?
And how about giving a lot of
incentives for that procedure?
And I find it very
creepy, looking back,
particularly their hubris.
And of course,
other countries took
what we recommended via our
World Bank and Mr. McNamara
and did awful things
with their populations.
You're thinking of India
and the sterilizations that
were virtually forced
upon people there
as part of our progressive
ideal of population reduction.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Let's get
a couple more questions.
Fellow back there, and then
there's on up here too.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So my question is, it seems
that with the Great Society,
there is a certain
appeal to nobility.
There's a higher aim towards
it, the eradication of poverty.
So that's a very
idealistic sentiment,
but also a noble one.
Is there a way of introducing
a nobility into free market
economics that simply isn't
rooted in self-interest
to provide a sort of greater
appeal that would move folks
in my generation--
I'm a little younger than
some of the people here--
and allow them to move
forward in a productive way?
AMITY SHLAES: Well, I think
one thing you're talking about
is the transactional
nature of Silicon Valley.
I'll never know the
counterparty in this deal.
I'm selling him x, y, z,
and I don't care about him.
But that's not most of commerce.
Most of free market is everyone
you meet, you will meet again.
Every person you ever
meet in your life
will remember the
encounter with you
and how you handled
the transaction.
And were you kind?
And did you under-deliver
or over-deliver?
That's what one
always tells students.
You think you'll never
see someone again.
You will always
see everyone again,
and everyone will
always remember
your tie, what color
it was, or your scarf,
and were you polite or did
you talk to someone else,
and did you cheat him.
So there is a natural
morality to commerce.
Because when you sell
something to someone,
they remember that,
if you cheated them.
Life, most of us
avoid bad airports
because bad airports lie to us.
They advertise a close
gate, and then we
find we have to walk
2 miles to the gate.
They say we have
a boarding pass,
and then we're unseated, right?
So we know, when we can
to avoid bad airports,
which are, say,
low-trust places.
And we look for
high-trust places
where the airport is even
nicer than we thought,
and maybe it has free coffee.
I think they have
that in Toronto.
So I like that, and
that's not socialism.
That's good commerce, right?
So I think we have to
think about the kindness
and the morality in
commerce, and expose it.
Let's think of it
this way. eBay--
when we were young,
people my age,
again, we wouldn't have
believed that eBay could work.
Because you send your
money off to someone
in another state
who nobody you know
knows, and he or she sends you
back more or less the thing
you ordered, right?
More or less.
And sometimes it's a part which
you haven't inspected yourself,
like a car part.
Oh, my gosh, and
it might be flawed
in some way where that
other person could
say he technically
sent you a good thing
but the thing is useless to you.
And we might send $185 for a car
part if we're building a car.
And yet, most of the
time, eBay works.
Most of the time, most
of us are satisfied
with eBay and say, that is an
incredibly wonderful economy
where the people don't
cheat each other.
There's a kind of broker ref.
That would be the eBay company.
And most of the time--
and the same is for Airbnb.
Most of the time, you
don't get murdered.
[LAUGHTER]
Most of the time, even
on Craigslist, you
don't get-- now, most of
the time on Craigslist,
you don't get cheated.
The stories that you hear in
Uber, they're the exception.
So there's a lot of evidence
of a great commercial economy
involving a lot of
kindness and respect
for fellow men and a lot
of utils to put it in,
a lot of benefit to people,
that is underappreciated.
MATTHEW SPALDING: I was thinking
of Reagan's great retort
was the Creative Society.
AMITY SHLAES: Right.
Reagan is a very sad
character in this book.
He loses his job at GE, and
he can't get any good roles.
But he does give a good
speech for Barry Goldwater,
and then he decides he might
run for governor of California.
And he says, what am
I going to call it?
And he actually
goes to a minister,
and they come up with--
or the minister already
has and offers
Creative Society, which
is what the companies are.
Do think the Intel people--
when they started and were
at Fairchild, did they
think they could ever
invent something that
would be so useful?
No.
They also believed
that everything
you ever did in their area
was in service of government.
They were stuck in the
military industrial--
what do you build computer
parts, electronics for?
The government.
Only the government can
have a big computer, right?
MATTHEW SPALDING: No one
else would use these.
AMITY SHLAES: Nobody
else would use it.
And what they realized--
and I follow them,
and you can see it
dawning on them.
And it is like the sun
coming into their life--
is somebody might buy what I'm
making who's not a government.
And somebody might
buy enough of it
that I would have
money for research
to invent something that
wouldn't be for government.
That's the story of Bob
Noyce and Gordon Moore.
They have a few epiphanies.
One is Moore's Law, which is you
can make smaller chips pretty
soon.
And there's a kind of
geometric acceleration there.
But the other is, wow,
big companies that
make technical things in STEM
actually serve regular people,
and there's a tremendous
relief at that discovery.
And Reagan doesn't
really get it.
He only sort of gets it.
But he has an
intuitive appreciation
for the entrepreneurial
because to be an actor,
you have to be entrepreneurial.
You have a lot of humiliation,
a lot of highs, a lot of--
MATTHEW SPALDING:
A lot of failure.
AMITY SHLAES: A lot of failure.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: To what
extent do you credit--
AMITY SHLAES: Where--
AUDIENCE: Sorry, right--
AMITY SHLAES: Oh, [INAUDIBLE].
MATTHEW SPALDING: Right here.
AUDIENCE: Right here, sorry.
To what extent do you credit--
because going on parallel
to the start of the Great
Society is the civil
rights movement.
To what extent do
you credit the fact
that the civil rights
movement now would largely
be seen as a positive
use of federal power
over localities in
order to achieve
a common good of expanding civil
rights throughout the nation
as a convincing mechanism for
people who might otherwise have
been cautious as a society of
what the federal government can
do and might have had a greater
trust in their localities?
The civil rights movement
seems to have, to me, reversed
the presumption that
the localities were,
in fact, trustworthy.
AMITY SHLAES: Right, because
only 8% of people, black,
are registered to vote in
Mississippi, a tragedy,
at the beginning, it's
wrong, needs fixed, right?
Therefore, we must bus
every kid in every city
across the northern
part of America,
is what you're describing.
Because the federal
government intervened--
and some of those feel rightly--
with the Civil Rights Act and
then the Voting Rights Act,
which was subsequent,
we gave it license
to intervene everywhere and
write policy for all towns.
Yeah, of course, I credit it.
It's a hard call
because something
had to happen in the south
if only 8% of a certain group
are registered to vote.
I don't know how to fix that.
In the book, what I say is the
Voting Rights Act and the Civil
Rights Law, I don't
think were negative.
They were positive.
But when we began to move, as
Johnson did with his 1960--
I think it's '65 speech at
Howard University, where
he basically signed up
for affirmative action
and something beyond
equality of opportunity,
moving to equality
of result, that
was an overstep because you
always disappoint people when
you promise equality of result.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Amity,
this is wonderful.
I'm thoroughly enjoying it--
the people, the stories.
I'm going to give the
last point to you.
What would you like
to add or suggest
that we've not talked about?
AMITY SHLAES: I think the
thing that surprised me most
in writing this book was the
importance of labor unions.
Labor unions are
hard to understand.
They have their own language.
They have their own
court, the NLRB.
What is-- it most of
the time, most people
don't understand
what's going on.
But what happened,
basically in the '60s,
was the labor unions were the
core of the Democratic Party,
much more so than today,
as many of you know,
because of the way our laws
have changed and some restraint
and because of the weakness
of our labor unions.
And they decided what happened.
An example, there was
a big student movement
that started at Port
Huron, Michigan.
The Port Huron
Statement is legendary.
And what I didn't
know till I researched
this book was that
Port Huron meeting
of Tom Hayden, who
became a legendary SDS
person, and Michael
Harrington and a few others,
was essentially made possible
by the AFL-CIO and the UAW.
Not only that, but Hayden
was later paid by the UAW
to do the little mischief he
did in Newark, New Jersey.
And what is tragic
and a good story
is Walter Reuther, the head
of the United Auto Workers,
I regard as a kind
of fool, flawed hero.
Walter Reuther just thought,
well, let's have a youth wing.
What's wrong with funding youth?
A lot of them are
going to go to college.
Well, that's more
members for my union.
Maybe I could have 2 million
members instead of 1 million
in the United Auto Workers and
squeeze out those Teamsters.
So I'm going to put them on
a long leash, those students.
Well, they're wild.
Well, I was wild.
I went to Russia.
They're wild, and I'll
look the other way
and hope that if I fund
them and love them and be
like their dad,
then later they'll
come and be loyal to me.
And instead, what
those students did--
the Students for a
Democratic Society was wild.
They did ruin the
Chicago convention-- was
hand the election of 1968 to
Walter Reuther's opponent.
Oh, so bitter.
Imagine the Passover scenes.
Imagine the family dinners.
Reuther just couldn't
believe that the youth
would turn against
him, he who did
so much for them and his union.
And what's very
sad about Reuther
was he actually died
not of disappointment,
but in one of those rickety,
wrong, early Learjets.
He was in a terrible
plane crash going
to a kind of utopian
place in Black
Lake, Michigan
that he had built,
a retreat for union workers.
But it is symbolic because his
dream of a Social Democratic
America also died at that point.
So that, I didn't know.
And if you come from the Midwest
and are of a certain age,
you heard Walter Reuther's name
every night of your childhood,
along with the Vietnam
War count, right?
The casualties were
and Walter Reuther
said, because the unions
were so important.
So I will say, I learned
a lot about them.
They're not that complicated.
They were wrong.
They're an example
of lovable people
trying to help other people and
doing something that does not
have a positive result.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Amity, it's
been great having you here.
Thank you very much.
AMITY SHLAES: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW SPALDING: I have
so much enjoyed your work
on your book on Coolidge,
and your work Coolidge
is wonderful.
But these two books, The
Forgotten Man and The New Deal,
if you've not read that,
I really recommend.
That, and now this new
history of the Great Society,
will be the contrarian
but very important
books on liberalism
in the 20th century.
So thank you very much.
AMITY SHLAES: Thank you.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Thank
you all for joining us.
[APPLAUSE]